North Korea has fired a ballistic
missile over Northern Japan the Japanese
government warned its citizens to take
cover and was forced to suspend some
train services in Northern regions the
missile was launched off North Korea's
east coast and fell into the Pacific
Ocean it was pyongyang's fifth round of
weapons testing in the last 10 days
a ballistic missile launch that flew
over our country is not only an issue
for aircraft and vessels it's also a
serious and problematic action that
involves the safety of residents living
in the area where the missile flew over
we have strongly protested against North
Korea in the strongest terms so let's
bring in Robert Kelly he's a professor
of international relations at Busan
National University joins us live from
Busan in South Korea Robert good to have
you back with us so we know that North
Korea has fired a series of ballistic
missiles recently why is this one so
different in terms of its range and
height and its timing
yeah well flying over Japan is obviously
a real risk right I mean as you saw as
your your reporter mentioned the
Japanese government actually told people
to take shelter
um this is something the Japanese
haven't done in a while and there's
actually been a debate in Japan about
whether or not there should be civil
defense whether or not
the Japanese government should make an
effort to actually try to prepare the
Japanese citizenry for North Korean
missile strikes my own sense is that the
North Koreans don't actually intend to
strike Japan that this is sort of Fairly
typical North Korean Behavior insofar as
they just don't really care about the
sovereignty of the states around them
you may recall that they once launched a
missile test that went Southward and the
missile broke up near the Philippines
and they just don't care that much and
this is of course you know one of the
great troubles that we have with North
Korea is that they just don't follow the
rules very much and this is I think a
really good example of that yeah and
that's an interesting point you make
Robert because this is the fifth time
that a North Korean missile has flown
directly over Japan with the Japanese
government even warning its people to
take cover but listen despite that
strong condemnation Japan seems pretty
powerless to do anything about these
launches though
yeah and I think we all are which is to
say South Korea in the United States as
well it's not really clear to me what we
can do to stop these things if there was
some obvious magic bullet or some really
clear solution we would have tried it
already I'm having some ideas we should
try to use missile defense to shoot down
these tests on both Japan and South
Korea have missile defense systems both
their own and U.S systems installed
perhaps you could do that but missile
defense doesn't work very well it's very
hard to actually hit the target it's
sort of analogous to hitting a bullet
with a bullet and people are concernable
if we miss does that make it look like
missile defense won't work very well
um you know I suppose you could do sir
preemptive strikes but in that of course
is hugely risky and so that's why these
things keep happening right we keep
talking about sort of a tough response
that's what the South Korean president
said this morning but it's just not
clear to me what that would be right
that wouldn't put us on a war footing
yeah let's just stay with that for a
second Robert because I mean you're
there in South Korea how do you see the
South Korean response playing out is
this just a war of words or could we see
some kind of military response and and
what could that mean
it's almost certainly going to be
rhetorical again because that's what
we've seen in the past in South Korea
and Japan are both fairly vulnerable to
North Korean missile strikes as I said
missile defense doesn't work very well
right I mean we could do more of it I
think I would like to see both Japan and
South Korea really invest in this I
think it's the best shot we have to have
some kind of roof but it doesn't really
work terribly well you know sanctions
North Korea is already pretty heavily
sanctioned we could do something more
extreme like trying to quarantine it the
way we would quarantine Cuba during the
Cuban Missile Crisis but again that gets
us awfully close to a war footing I mean
I've heard these things sort of kicked
around you hear sort of these more
stream ideas every once in a while at
the conferences but I mean all of them
risk a major North Korean lashing out on
a major North Korean sort of provocation
response and we just don't know where
that would go if it would lead us into a
major conflict so we don't do it uh just
a final thought to you Robert what sort
of message then is North Korea trying to
send here what does Kim Jong-un actually
want this is about Pyongyang trying to
get the attention of the US and the
attention of Japan who you know have
largely ignored the North Korean leader
yeah I mean I think one way to read
these tests pretty frequently is that
there's sort of a demand for attention
North Korea doesn't like being
understood as the failed Korea or the
weird Korea or somehow it's not the real
one compared to South Korea which is of
course the truth and so one of the
things the North Koreans do is sort of
try to gen up our attention or grab our
attention through these kinds of hijinks
often around uh elections or
appointments or something like that
right to the American midterm elections
are coming up
um you know provoking Japan is always
sort of a winner in Korea because of the
difficult history in the past um but I'm
not it's not really clear to me there's
any one particular thing that North
Koreans are looking for from Japanese
um just generally you know they want a
missile program and that's pretty well
established and and so they're going to
continue to test and if they need to
send them south or send them East or
something like that you know they have a
record of doing that and they'll
probably continue to do it
Robert Kenny always good to get your
thoughts thank you very much indeed for
talking to larger Robert thank you